تعيش في قرية زراعية صغيرة في
الهند
، ومن غير المرجح
أن تصبح جدة لثمانية أشخاص من المشاهير على اليوتيوب بين عشية وضحاها ،
لكن هذا هو بالضبط ما فعلته
شركة حليب غانغافا من لا
بادابالي ، فهي نجمة مسلسل كوميدي
يُدعى
برنامج قريتي يشاهده الملايين
العمل عبر الإنترنت أعتقد أن الناس يحبون الطريقة التي
أتحدث بها ،
فأنا سيدة عجوز كما تعلمون
ولست متعلمة ، لم أنهي حتى
صفي الأول ، ولم أتخيل أبدًا أن
هذا العرض سيكون مثل هذا النجاح ،
وقد تمت مشاهدة هذا المنشور المحدد
أكثر  أكثر من 30 مليون مرة على موقع youtube ،
والذي قدم أيضًا لـ CNN لقطات
لهذه القصة ،
إنه الشخص الذي اكتشف موهبتها التمثيلية ،
إنها تتصرف بشكل طبيعي جدًا
أمام الكاميرا أمام الكاميرا ،
لذا من المفيد جدًا
أن يحب المعجبون هذا النوع من المواقف
فريقًا من  تسعة أشخاص يعملون في
برنامج قريتي
العام الماضي ، أرسل اليوتيوب لهم لوحة ذهبية
للوصول إلى مليون
مشترك من
خلال الإعلانات الموضوعة على مقاطع الفيديو
، ودخل ثابت هو عام.
أقيمت للقرية ، المرأة التي لم
تسافر أبدًا إلى أبعد من القرية التالية
أصبحت الآن شخصية
مشهورة على YouTube [تصفيق]
كما تم إبراز مواهبها على هذه
الشاشة الفضية
في أفلام بلغة التيلجو.
ألتقط صور سيلفي مع الأشخاص الذين يأتون
لزيارة القرية هناك  هناك الكثير من
الأشخاص الذين يأتون إلى هنا لرؤيتي
تقول إحساس الهند على اليوتيوب إنها
تريد الاستمرار في زيادة جمهورها
وإظهار معجبيها أن أي شخص يمكن أن
يحلم بشكل كبير